Disney's latest movie Zootopia has
something for everyone
cute talking animals a positive message
of social acceptance crack-cocaine truly
a movie for the whole family
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show that
makes it slightly less creepy that I'm
sitting solo in a movie theater watching
a Disney movie surrounded by screaming
children but seriously I love Disney
movies in a time where the world is so
full of fear hate and YouTube rage
comments nice to visit a bright colorful
fantasy world where things are simpler
happier ah Who am I kidding Disney
movies aren't dark Bambi's mom dies
pinocchio gets kidnapped and sold into
slavery scar gets eaten alive but
Zootopia may just be the darkest of the
bunch if you haven't seen it you totally
should right now in fact not only is it
a fun movie but this video is just
riddled with spoilers so consider
yourself warned to get you up those
utopia tells the story of Judy Hopps an
ambitious young rabbit who fulfills her
dream of becoming the first rabbit
police officer in the history of this
all Animal Society here in Zootopia
predators and prey coexist peacefully
but some predators have mysteriously
gone missing as of late and it's up to
judy to crack the case not only is it a
really fun detective story of Zootopia
also shine some light on really
important social issues like how gosh
darn slow the DMV is gosh simultaneously
hilarious just downright depressing but
when you look beyond it's cute animals
as humans cover Zootopia is truly a
story about race the idea of the
minority group in society the Predators
facing prejudice and mistreatment from
the majority is a pretty thinly veiled
allusion to America's spotty history of
race relations don't believe me we see
an ice cream parlor refused to serve a
predator police being quicker to draw
weapons against predators and even Judy
hypothesizes that predators are
biologically more savage than parade and
those are some heavy themes I feel bad
for those parents who made the
responsible choice take their kids to
Zootopia instead of Deadpool a good idea
but now I have to try and explain
eugenics to a four-year-old
but while the Zootopia is about racism
concepts may not be surprising to an
astute viewer it goes even deeper than
that
because this children's movie about a
rabbit and just wants to be a cop is
actually a retelling of a long-standing
conspiracy theory that crack cocaine was
devised destroy black communities in
America that you didn't see that one
coming
Oh timeout Matt Pat you the skeptical
viewer are probably shouting Disney may
go dark but they don't go that dark hey
I understand your skepticism but Disney
is no stranger to drug use remember when
Dumbo drinks some water that has
champagne in it and gets so wasted that
he hallucinates pink elephants and wakes
up hungover in a tree or when Alice from
Alice in Wonderland eats some special
mushrooms that make her perceptions of
reality change and when it comes to
drugs there's even a Breaking Bad joke
in the movie and if you want to see how
dark Disney is willing to go did you
watch Maleficent if you did you probably
understand that that was pretty much a
fairy tale retelling of the story of a
rape survivor yeah Disney makes fun
animated movies that are for kids but
they sure aren't afraid to tackle some
pretty intense stuff for the benefit of
the adults in the audience so why not
crack cocaine and by that I mean why
would they not talk about crack cocaine
and not why shouldn't we all do crack
cocaine crack is wack kids just say no
other Reagan era slogans know obviously
the movies characters don't smoke actual
crack but Zootopia has its own substance
called night howlers and the
similarities between crack and night
howlers are pretty surprising one last
reminder that it's about to strike
spoiler o'clock so if you're afraid of
turning back into a pumpkin it's time to
run away from the ball now the ball
being this video added that metaphor
just spun wildly out of control spoilers
ahead let's go
evidence number one night howler serum
and crack are both synthesized from
harmless plants as we see in Zootopia
night howlers they're flowers that grow
wild and Judy's parents carrot farm
nobody had any idea that they were key
to some psychotropic drug until a fox
tells them so even after they've been
harvested Judy mistakes the bulbs for
onions when she stops a weasel who's
stealing them to turn them into night
howler serum similarly if you took crack
cocaine back to its most basic form
you'd probably walk right on past it
without another thought crack and
cocaine in general comes from the leaves
of the coca plants which is indigenous
to much of South and Central America raw
so harmless that most people make it
into tea or put it into habit-forming
sodas back in the day but concentrating
coca extract from several pounds of
leaves results in a few grams of pure
Colombian nose candy of course then you
have to chemically treat the powder
version of cocaine and cook it to turn
it into crack so there is a lot of lab
work that goes into turning leaves into
crack and in Zootopia we get a good look
at the complicated chemistry lab used to
produce night holler serum by dug the
sheep and his partners given the variety
and sophistication of equipment we see
in the lab it's reasonable to conclude
that synthesizing night holler serum and
crack cocaine are similar processes but
this leads to one question why crack and
not something like say crystal meth I
mean again there's a Breaking Bad
reference in the scene after all well
here's the thing
crystal meth isn't made from living
plant matter max active ingredients are
usually synthesized from chemical
sources like cough medicine besides we
all know that the only use Walter White
has for flowers is poisoning innocent
children oh isn't this a happy episode
can't wait for this one to get suggested
against all those Disney toy unboxing
videos anyway let's cheer things up a
bit here's a cute picture of a sloth oh
oh look at this guy all right back to
crack evidence number two night howlers
and crack cocaine effect user in the
same way well Zootopia doesn't tell us a
whole lot about what it's like to be a
night owl or serum we can get some clues
by observing those who are under its
influence Emmitt Otterton scratches up
the entire back seat of his limousine
rambles incoherently about the night
howlers and then attacks his driver for
no reason when Judy goes to question the
driver we see that the night howlers
effect animals almost instantly as one
second they're having a pleasant
conversation and the next he goes
full-on rage virus on earth so night
howler effects include mania
incoherence and near-instant aggression
how does this compare with crack
speaking from personal experience I have
no idea no experience in the drug realm
trust me we go to some pretty crazy
lengths to research these episodes but
uh not that far I'm not passing out
crack pipes in the Edit room and taking
notes however a butt ton of Internet
research shows that it matches up pretty
well effects of smoking crack include
restless
this anxiety irritability and in large
doses aggression paranoia and delusions
running through walls however not on
that list sorry Dave as for how fast you
feel the effects of crack after you've
smoked it it's hard to locate an exact
number but smoking the drug is the
fastest way to get it into your
bloodstream outside of injecting it and
some of the most official sounding
people on the internet talking about
crack claim that it works almost
instantly
obviously the drugs aren't meant to be
exactly the same this is an allegory
after all but based on their effects
they might as well be evidence number
three night howlers and crack effect the
same groups
Zootopia makes a point to make sure that
we know that predators are the minority
and that predators are the only ones
quote-unquote going savage as a result
of the night howl or serum well the
movie doesn't explicitly tell us which
minority predators are it's pretty clear
that we're talking about African
Americans I alluded to it before but we
see Nick Wilde the Fox denied service at
an ice cream parlor simply because he's
a predator and the tension between
zootopia's police force and predators is
a transparent allusion to the issues
brought up in the hashtag black lives
matter movement also assistant mayor
bellwether tells us that zootopia's
population is 10 percent predator a very
similar mark to the twelve point three
percent of the u.s. population that's
African American the Predators are also
all disappearing from zootopia's
precinct one which is referred to as the
city center when judy is assigned to it
at her graduation from the police
academy
all of this mirrors the group that was
hit hardest by crack cocaine in the
1980s inner-city African Americans a
paper by future Freakonomics Steven
Levitt stated that the incidence of
crack usage per capita was ten times as
high in large cities with low-income
urban populations such as New York
Philadelphia and Washington DC crack
also affected black communities really
disproportionately as during the crack
boom of the 80s and early 90s
eighty-five percent of arrests made
related to crack were of African
Americans I'm sure some of you are
probably still skeptical sure night
hollers make you act like you're on
crack affected minority communities and
come from plans so what in this movie
there's a big government conspiracy
around the night howlers assistant mayor
bellwether is the one
the drug getting spread developing a
serum that her minions administer to
predators via dart gun she admits that
she began the conspiracy to ensure that
the prey majority could keep the peace
by making everyone afraid of predators
as she puts it fear always works it's
not like in real life there was some big
government conspiracy to provide African
Americans with crack out of paranoia for
national safety right price
well evidence number four night howlers
and crack are both government
conspiracies there are some og theorists
out there who believe that the crack
cocaine epidemic back in the 1980s came
from a similar kind of government
conspiracy as that shown in Zootopia
before I go on let me take a minute to
get serious I should mention that this
is a really controversial theory and not
one to take lightly if you're interested
in any of this do some research and
reading for yourself there's no way that
in the final minutes of my video on
Zootopia that I can give this topic the
true depth and explanation that it
deserves it's my goal with the show to
just inspire you guys to learn more
about the world around you and not
always take news stories at face value
anyway regardless of the truth of this
theory it reeks of the events depicted
in Zootopia in 1996 a San Jose
journalist named Gary Webb wrote a
three-part report called Dark Alliance
which exposed a complicated web of
connections between the American
government and the spread of crack
cocaine in the predominantly
african-american neighborhood of South
Los Angeles like I've already said it's
a really complicated story that I won't
get too deep into here but basically
America afraid of the spread of
communism during the Cold War supported
a guerrilla resistance group known as
the Contras not those gorillas gorillas
though it's an easy mistake considering
that this is utopia you know what never
mind just views gorillas use the
gorillas and know the Contras is not
referring to the old NES game anyway the
support of the Contras resulted in the
CIA becoming involved with a bunch of
drug smugglers and this is 100% true a
Senate report confirmed that the drug
traffickers had been provided with
federal money once the funding for the
Contras ran out they were given the
green light to raise money for
themselves and how do you do that if
you're a small Central American country
lemonade stands bake sales nope drugs
they flooded the west coast with cheap
cocaine while the government willingly
look the other way or as some speculate
provided planes to aid in the shipment
of the narcotics between countries by
1987 crack was ravaging practically all
of America's large cities hitting
low-income black neighborhoods the
hardest the dealer who started it all a
man by the name of Ricky Ross believes
that spreading crack to African
Americans was a conscious choice by the
government one that then President
Ronald Reagan made out of a desire to
keep the country safe from the Soviet
Union and the spread of communism
Ross has said quote I believe that they
felt it was more valuable to sacrifice a
particular sector of America and a race
of people in America in order to save
the whole country end quote
it's an idea that mayor Lionheart echoes
towards the end of Zootopia saying that
they did quote the wrong thing for the
right reasons
end quote Zootopia even seems like it's
making references to specific instances
of the crack epidemic in the movie mayor
Lionheart gets set up to make it look
like he's behind the night howlers
scheme and gets put in jail only to
return to power after his release it's
awfully similar to Washington DC Mayor
Marion Barry who was caught smoking
crack jailed and then re-elected as
mayor when he was released from prison
stay classy DC long story short the
level of government involvement with a
spread of crack in America is still in
question but if I ever go missing no it
was the government silencing me for this
video or the one where I researched
atomic bombs and Batman or my old
polybius video back on game theory man
I've got to be on so many watch lists at
this point anyway there you have it
Zootopia educating our children about a
government conspiracy to spread an
organic rage drug to inner-city minority
groups that it makes you yearn for the
simpler days of princesses with
Stockholm Syndrome but hey that's just a
theory a depressing theory and a
conspiracy theory but most of all a film
theory
and cut